twitch chat is an important part of the
experience for many eSports fans for
years Kappa has been one of Twitch's
most popular events but it has recently
been challenged by an unlikely contender
that's right people we're doing try hard
so over this highly controversial email
come from and why is it one of Twitch's
most popular to answer the question we
have to go all the way back to a 2012
anime convention in Texas at a con 23
popular streamer and speedrunner likely
trihex jefferson posed for this image
excited after having his Dragon Ball Z
wall scroll autographed and a bit
nervous near a cute girl that he met at
the panel trihex gave us this now famous
expression you know me I'm losing my
spaghetti because I thought the girl is
really cute I made like this really
awkward cringe smile it's it's it's
actually kind of crazy because people
always asked me like can you recreate
the face and it's such an awkward smile
that I kind of can't well it quickly
became a meme among his own followers
triaxis expression wouldn't become a
global emote until later that year after
it was suggested by some of his
followers in a thread on the twitch
forums about a week later a twitch admin
showed up in try hexxus stream and the
speedrunner decided to show off a bit by
playing through one of Yoshi's islands
hardest levels so I stopped everything
like the run like I got stop the run
that was in the middle of because it
wasn't good run anyway didn't matter and
I immediately put on like beating the
beast be our guest be our guest put that
song on full blast and looks like the
hardest level I could and it was like yo
choice tab let's go nuts about to [__]
it up and deny um I could like the
harness off like Han and I'm like
pounding on my controller the admin
asked why are you trying so hard and the
rest is history
the e mode became trihard so that
explains where the e mode came
but how did it become so popular even
temporarily overtaking kapa in the past
to answer that we have to talk about
memes more generally when a mean becomes
very popular it's often because it
conveys information whose meaning format
or both allow it to spread easily often
this is because the meme is easily
understood check out our video on tea
lizard for more on that trihard can be a
panic smile like when you like I don't
know got the glass of milk and you're
like it can be a panic smile it can be a
cringe smile it can be it can be a play
on the pun of the title itself however
it would ultimately become popularized
by one notorious twitch streamer ice
poseidon there are 36 million dry hearts
ever said on Twitch 24 million out of
the 36 million try-hards ever said Thank
You Josh I love you dog for the sub I
have been said inside of this channel
now that is and that is not like like
it's so stupid bro when you when you do
what he does with the whole IRL thing
you feel like every day you have to top
yourself to feel confident about
yourself on your streams so it's like
when you have that go on there's a long
period of time when you grow organic as
a twitch streamer and you have getting
no moderation this little Grimer like
becomes a full adult muck and just
because it's like just giant slobbing
beast of a cat culture so you come in
there and you know you can be a full
[__] because there's no monster
timing anyone out or even doing anything
you know no slow mode though nothing so
winning winning got to like you know
5,000 viewers they just naturally do the
one thing that could do the good
attention because nothing extension
anymore because everyone should post a
long time so what you got to do you
become a I'm guessing a racist [__] or
whatever his streams chat is responsible
for over 38 million uses of trihard the
most of any individual streamer and
nearly 20% of all tryhard emotes used
but that's what I imagine
have it I'm the heat deliberately did
anything it was just a case of Czech
culture doing its own thing
ice beside it and his legion of
followers have seen to it the trihard
spread even into the physical world this
is evident in an incident where someone
managed to prank ice by unfurling a
massive trihard banner in the background
of one of his videos or the time ice
himself even had a feei custom-made the
face printed on the hood and side
panelist the reason that the emote is
contentious is that not everyone has the
same idea of what trihard should be it
has also become a shorthand response
used by some to seeing a black person on
stream for example when hearthstone pro
Terence M made it to the grand finals at
Dreamhack Austin 2016 his appearance was
met with a torrent of racist chat
messages many accompanied by the trihard
emote one of the channels moderators
even got in on the act
eventually as the moderators struggled
to stem the flow the emote itself was
actually banned from the channel the
idea expressed by one of the channels
moderators after the fact that the
trihard emote is not inherently racist
is one that the emotes creator shares
once you remove trihard and youth you
know what you're telling the [__]
posters oh we do get triggered and your
negative things do get to us so then
it's gonna be a new games going to be oh
we could be able to try hard we can be
offensive shooters of every other emote
and we can just make them forever remove
things because we're so we're such an
influencing power like you're empowering
negativity actually by removing in on
the other hand there are those that
choose to restrict the emotes use for
one reason or another at a diversity
panel at twitchcon in 2016 streamer DJ
Knight explained that while his stream
was featured on the front page
which he issued a one second explanatory
timeout for users who use the trihard
emote not that I have anything against
the trihard emote just get rid of it
because if somebody drops that emote
before they say any words guarantee the
next things out of their mouths gonna be
something ridiculous so I just had it on
a quick timeout one second look shut up
and then I would come in like hey look I
see you got timed out cuz you try hard
evil yes I'm a person who felt I'm black
that's not there's nothing to change
that I like my skin tone but if you want
to talk there's a chat box feel free to
chat you're gonna talk I'm here let's
talk about something ask me a question
don't just pop in an e mode because you
see on the brother on twitch and what
felt good was that a lot of people once
I was like I hit what that was like oh
let me say something hi how you doing
sorry Triax is fine with channels that
choose to ban or otherwise restrict the
trihard e mode but he said that proper
moderation at least initially can help
avoid the problem before it even begins
the conversation you're not having with
twitch chat or your own chat is a
conversation on its own by not voicing
your opposition to whatever you don't
find a tolerable you're indirectly
letting them know that it's okay to do
that so for people who are outright
banning the e mail or banning any emo or
whatever they may be doing I have to go
back here and think how many months did
you let this happen before you finally
said alright I'm tired of it like [__]
off or whatever and then you like you
know cuz you can you can you can you can
make that intolerant they've been very
jump and people will know that the
Canada who can't do that so therein lies
the contradiction with trihard it isn't
inherently racist nor did it start with
any sort of racist intention in mind
it definitely owes a lot of its success
to its one-of-a-kind expression and all
the uses that viewers could imagine for
it and they could certainly imagine
quite a lot like pogchamp and Kappa it
has become an expression that resonated
with its users so much that it is
transcended twitch and expanded to other
forms of
while part of its popularity is due to
shitposting it's impossible to know
exactly just how much but for me at
least the purest form of the meme will
always be that awkward impossible face
staring wide-eyed into the distance
trying desperately not to lose his
spaghetti as for the future of the emo
trihex says he's not trying to control
its path instead he wants to see where
it will go I find fascinating
interesting and honestly fulfilling
it's a privilege because if they give
emotes if the emotes sucked and was
uninteresting or like too niche it
wouldn't it would naturally end like
emotes will naturally come to an
invisible out of their of their purpose
and and cultural journey and become a
relic and have like a complete Wikipedia
article with nothing more to add because
there's nothing more happening to it
trihard has [__] happening to it in year
5 and still going on like the legacy is
still currently being written and that's
something you have to appreciate the the
stupidest thing and the most
disrespectful thing I can do is stop at
is like you know put a cap on it or
whatever so I'm all for letting trihard
rampage through the through the
everything but no matter where trihard
ends up and whatever your take on the
emote maybe it's impossible to deny its
impact on the larger mean landscape
look Josh we have to do a trihard video
no no way no way that's way too volatile
asking for it look did you just hand me
a printed YouTube comments well I mean
the commenter is named a smart guy so he
probably knows what's up but you know
what no no I'm look what will it take
for you to do a try-hard video alright
you know what a lot of three things
first off I want a tea lizard and a
smoking video secondly I want a glad
plain video and the third thing I want
is for trihex himself to appear in the
video and you know what if he's out I'm
out but none of that is ever gonna
happen we'll see about that
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]